Three y plus two divided by y plus eight is correct. Great effort if you got
this one correct. Here, the L-C-D is y plus two. These are the only factors that
appear in the denominators inside of our complex fraction. We know we need to
multiply by the L-C-D divided by the L-C-D. So we really just distribute this to
each of our terms and our complex fraction. Next we simplify the common factors
from a numerator and denominator. This leaves us with 1 times y plus 2 here, 2y
here, 4 times y plus 2 in our denominator, and a negative 3y also in our
denominator. We can clean up this fraction by adding our light terms here to get
3y plus 2. We can also distribute this 4 and our denominator. Giving us 4y plus
8 minus 3y. We add like terms one more time to get our final fraction. You're a
pro. Way to go.